[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
el macrojuicio iniciado esta semana en
parís a propósito de los atentados de
noviembre de 2015 nos acompañan en este
estudio eusebio va al corresponsal de la
vanguardia en francia bienvenido al
serbio hola buenos días paula martínez
infante periodista independiente
bienvenida y en dúplex alexandra hill
periodista de investigación experto en
yihadismo y autora del libro en el
vientre de la llegada alexandra buenos
días
el macrojuicio por los atentados de
noviembre de 2015 hoy en primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues francia vuelve a recordar el
horror de noviembre de 2015 ya ha
arrancado en parís el macroproceso por
los atentados del 13 de noviembre de
2015 en los que murieron 130 personas y
350 resultaron heridas la mayoría en la
sala bataclán lo recuerdan se ha
establecido un dispositivo de seguridad
excepcional para los 9 meses que durará
el proceso así como una sala
especialmente creada para este juicio
extraordinario en el que se juzgará a 20
personas entre ellas 5 que están
ausentes por presunción de muerte un
dato la sala del gran juicio tiene 700
metros cuadrados que sin embargo no
serán suficientes para acoger a todos
los participantes en este acontecimiento
judicial como se pueden imaginar muchas
portadas en francia- dedicadas esta
semana a este macroproceso como la del
diario libération proceso del 13 de
noviembre plantar cara en el corazón de
la investigación dice el católico lakua
con una foto en portada de la sala
especial para el juicio señalando la red
tentacular que llegaba hasta el corazón
del estado islámico le para visión
recuerda la noche que dejó en shock a
francia y la revista love un proceso
para la historia lo primero de todo
eusebio que esperan ustedes de este
macroproceso bueno pues la verdad es que
ha habido una casi una saturación
mediática no estos días previos al
inicio del proceso y yo no creo que
vayan a salir
revelaciones espectaculares más allá de
lo que conocemos quizás algún detalle
sobre el complot nuevo pero no creo que
vaya a cambiar mucho sobre lo que ya se
ha investigado y lo que es público lo
que pasa que este tipo de procesos
tienen una misión de catarsis para
alguna sociedad traumatizada van a
hablar muchas víctimas familiares
entonces eso sí que tiene puede tener un
efecto digamos moral para esta sociedad
y aparte están también las
responsabilidades de los servicios de
seguridad de la policía saber si
actuaron
de manera diligente si hubieran podido
evitar esto hubieran podido reaccionar
mejor pero yo creo que hay otro elemento
muy importante que quizás ahora no está
en el primer plano y es el gran debate
de la de la convivencia en esta sociedad
francesa con una minoría musulmana sobre
todo con una minoría musulmana
radicalizada ese es el gran tema de
futuro que de momento que en este país
hay un debate en otros no lo hay en
españa no no no existe que creo que esto
se puede revitalizar en los próximos
meses el efecto moral quizá también
podremos hablar de memoria histórica
pero no se coincide paula en que no
muchas más revelaciones de lo que ya
conocemos como el relato de lo que pasó
por supuesto y sobre todo hay que
considerar también que lo que se espera
es que uno de los principales acusados
de este este proceso que es el
terrorista que sobrevivió a los ataques
perdón puede hablar que durante este
martes la sala de slam que durante seis
años se ha refugio en un mutismo
absoluto no ha dicho nada y los primeros
días del proceso ya estamos en el tercer
día se ha permitido
desafiando actitud desafiante y utilizar
este juicio y toda la atención mediática
como lleno de riesgo que una también y
si lo ha dicho categóricamente yo sigo
siendo un soldado del estado islámico
entonces qué pasa con este proceso
también es una expresión máxima de lo
que es el estado de derecho en francia
por una parte es cierto que hay un
millón de páginas que en otros 42
volúmenes que se tienen que estudiar hoy
día se cuenta en detalle durante 8 horas
de hablar 3 personas qué es lo que pasó
durante estos 6 años de investigación y
como bien lo dice sucedió también yo
pienso que este proceso histórico una es
por la envergadura de lo que pasó se 13
de noviembre por el trauma colectivo que
significó ese 13 de noviembre y por otra
parte de encontrar responsables también
si bien es cierto se sabe por supuesto
quienes son los ejecutantes de estos
atentados las responsabilidades
pertinentes e individuales de esto aún
no están esclarecidas y por otro lado
también lo hablaremos más tarde también
de nuevo escuchar las voces de las
víctimas que han estado bastante
callados durante este tiempo y esperar
para ellos también una suerte de reciben
resiliencia
misma pregunta que se espera de este
macroproceso que podrá definir la
justicia terminó y ésta no es sino sino
una prueba más de la importancia
traumática que tuvieron estos atentados
sostuvo que tuvo este ataque en
y memoria colectiva de un país también
en la memoria personal por supuesto de
cada víctima generacional por la
generación a la que tengo y por supuesto
es una huella de un importantísimo
calado para este país que se espera de
este juicio bueno quizás los más
curiosos esperen oír hablar hasta la
isla ya lo hemos oído en los primeros
días
pero considero que es una gran
oportunidad para que lo que espere lo
que creo que tiene que esperar la
sociedad francesa de este juicio es que
se escuche a las víctimas es un momento
de reparación y deberíamos esperar
precisamente eso que las víctimas tengan
su momento y que por qué porque estos
juicios son esenciales para la
reparación y para la resiliencia de esta
sociedad y para escribir esta esta
historia no prepararse y comprender lo
que sucedió y darles la palabra a ellas
reparación coincide un poco con lo que
decía eusebio más que revelaciones y
gracias efecto moral y a esa reparación
hacia la hace las víctimas no sé si es
muy difícil no reparar el daño causado
pero
y es importante en este tipo de
situaciones conocer la verdad
conocer la verdad es como un alivio que
se esclarezcan los puntos oscuros
ante una pérdida tan importante para una
familia
es como mínimo básico tener claro
qué es lo que pasó por qué pasó quién
fue el responsable
es un consuelo que es que es
insuficiente pero es el mínimo consuelo
este macroproceso será filmado y
guardado en los archivos nacionales para
la posterioridad esto demuestra también
que esta va a estar muy vinculado a la
memoria histórica de este país
totalmente y en este mismo contexto hay
que pensar memoria memoria recordar
cierto de memoria histórica permite
efectivamente ir atrás en los estos
violentos de un país darle dignidad de
nuevo a las voces de las víctimas y
también no repetir los errores del
pasado esa es la gran causa el gran
principio de esta memoria histórica y
efectivamente el 13 de noviembre que ha
guardado la memoria de muchas personas
de cómo sucedió víctimas directas o
indirectas de los atentados por supuesto
en francia particularmente en parís
también qué es lo que significó y ayer
trabajaba con chicos adolescentes al
respecto al tema y conversábamos qué
pasa con la memoria histórica muchos de
ellos tenían 10 años cuando pasó este
estos atentados y es importante
conversar y decir lo que sucedió también
encontrar las causas del problema ver
cómo un país entero se reconstruye
después de un atentado tan violento y
también de alguna parte la
responsabilidad del estado no hay que
dejarla de lado la responsabilidad el
estado y ver como más adelante hoy día
con un contexto de nuevo un poco
polvoriento no digamos de ebullición de
nueva política con algunos focos de iad
y porque pueden surgir por aquí por allá
ver de qué manera se pueden editar
nuevamente estos tipos de hechos que
afectan y que afectan muchísimo
a un país entero antes nombraba eusebio
uno de los debates tangenciales y aquí
en francia hay varios debates
tangenciales en este en este proceso
vamos a tratar algunos de ellos como los
servicios de inteligencia o como también
la situación en las cárceles porque una
de las cuestiones que más investigadores
andrew hill es la situación carcelaria
de yihadistas en los últimos años en
prisiones francesas focos de
radicalización que han estado bajo lupa
alessandra cómo ha sido la evolución de
esa situación desde que se produjeran
los atentados de noviembre de 2015
evidentemente ha desplegado un arsenal
de medidas no ha habido muchísimos
esfuerzos y finalmente parece que han
dado con su modelo
por aislar a los presos después por
mezclarlos con otros y finalmente han
dado con un modelo que se trata de
instaurar en las cárceles de francia
módulos para medir la radicalización de
los presos y en función de la
peligrosidad a la hora de adoctrinar a
otros presos por ejemplo pues se les
asigna un lugar en una cárcel a un
régimen penitenciario concreto 2014 fue
un año clave para la política
penitenciaria en francia no tanto 2015
pero 2014 fue un poco como la antesala
del problema los franceses que se habían
marchado a siria fueron sobre todo en
2014 el gran contingente de tal manera
que en enero de 2015 hablábamos de ir
más de 1500 personas que se habían
marchado a siria desde francia aunque
estaban implicadas directamente con la
yihad en siria desde francia y perdón en
2014 también llegó otra vertiente que es
esencial para comprender este fenómeno y
es que regreso a francia de manera
masiva al contingente que había ido a
hacer la yihad inglesa silenciosa más
silenciosa yihad en 2012 de 2011 2013
muchas personas se fueron y regresaron
en 2014 que sucedió que con este regreso
se cambiaron las dinámicas de poder en
la cárcel y como se han legitimado como
se ha legitimado este colectivo en
concreto estas ideologías en concreto en
la cárcel y esto favorece la expansión
favorece esa autoridad moral de
cualquier persona que haya viajado a
siria o irak o cualquier persona que
haya intentado perpetrar un atentado en
francia
y luego está el contexto porque es
fundamental hablar de ello de este
juicio del siglo que es bastante
sintomático el contexto se dan cuenta se
produce cuando se cumplen 20 años del
11-s creo que el serbio llegó de
corresponsal de eeuu poco después del
11-s el primer día de nuestros siglos
según muchos historiadores el que marcó
toda la la evolución de lo que llamamos
de siglo y cuyas consecuencias bueno
seguimos viendo en pleno recrudecimiento
de la amenaza islamista tras la victoria
talibán en afganistán que según los
expertos podría incluso envalentonar a
los extremistas del mundo es decir qué
contexto tan sintomático en el que se
produce este macrojuicio no sé si se
producen en el contexto este aniversario
yo creo que para francia es importante
también demostrar que el estado de
derecho funciona es decir una diferencia
fundamental con el 11-s es que allí
no sé ha habido juicios se han mantenido
a personas en guantánamo durante años en
una situación jurídica
totalmente en un limbo en un limbo
jurídico
entonces el contraste es evidente aquí
con todas las garantías que ofrece la
constitución las leyes se va a juzgar
durante nueve meses hasta a estas
personas que no son los protagonistas
fundamentales sólo hay uno de ellos vivo
pero yo creo que esto es importante
también para europa para demostrar que
que la lucha contra el yihadismo se ha
de hacer respetando unas normas porque
si no es darle de alguna manera la razón
a los que atacan a la democracia no si
se están violando
pues normas básicas de los estados de
derecho que por suerte en los que por
suerte vivimos yo creo que eso es una
diferencia fundamental respecto al 11-s
up ahora una breve frase de metro grado
público en eeuu como una expresión de
que el tribunal militar está tratando de
jugar a estas personas y de nuevo es la
expresión máxima del estado de derecho
francés que va a dar algo y dar un
ejemplo también va a sentar un
precedente tal vez para los próximos
proyectos que vendrán más adelante y de
qué manera un juicio no sabemos en
américa latina permite a la gente de
nuevo la reparación pero edad y justicia
es lo que siempre se ha gritado en todos
las américas latinas después las
dictaduras verdad y justicia es lo que
se pide hoy día y lo que están exigiendo
las víctimas no veremos al final de los
nueve meses de proceso hacemos una breve
pausa y enseguida volvemos en primera
plana
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas les contamos los
que hicieron américa latina y los que la
construyen hoy les contamos un mundo
hecho día a día por los que lo habitan
liberté égalité actual y ti
seguimos en primera plana hablando del
macrojuicio del juicio del siglo
iniciado esta semana en parís a
propósito de los atentados de noviembre
de 2015 lo hacemos con el corresponsal
de la vanguardia
eusebi oval con paula martínez infante
periodista independiente y en dúplex
alexandra he la autora del libro en el
vientre de la yihad estábamos hablando
del contexto en el que se produce este
macrojuicio un contexto del 20
aniversario del 11-s de la victoria de
los talibanes en afganistán y a esto le
añadimos el estado de alerta porque si
recuerdan hace un año se produjo otra
ola de atentados aquí en francia del que
recordamos quizá como más simbólico la
brutal decapitación del profesor samuel
para ti tras el comienzo de otro proceso
clave de ese terrible 2015 el juicio por
los atentados contra la revista satírica
echar libro y un supermercado judío
también en parís de nuevo ese miedo de
reavivar el terror puede aparecer ahora
durante estos meses no fue equivocado
esto esta semana por el ministro de
interior la dama que decía que
efectivamente francia no está en alerta
máxima y de hecho el dispositivo de
seguridad que está alrededor de ley de
la sitio dónde está haciendo este juicio
un poco de la alerta máxima en la cual
estamos
es un poco peligroso al mismo tiempo y
pienso yo de la parte de ministerio
interior decir cuidado estamos de nuevo
la atentado viene inmediatamente en la
alerta de atentado ha estado desde
siempre recordemos que después del 2015
en 2016 también con neeson hay no hay
que olvidarlo
siempre francia nunca ha bajado la
guardia respecto al plan vice pirata que
le llaman acá porque sabemos que la
amenaza terrorista está permanente lo
que ha cambiado es de modus operandi de
los terroristas hoy día ya no hay estos
grandes dispositivos con armas de guerra
como lo que sucedió el 13 de noviembre
sino hoy día cualquier persona digamos
que se reivindica del estado islámico
aparece una estación de trenes en un
lugar bien
solicitada por la gente por el público
saca un cuchillo y hace una una masacre
en pocos segundos entonces es verdad que
el atentado que las que digamos las
alertas atentados y el riesgo es elevado
no olvidemos el 15 de julio pasado al
qaeda lanzó
se filtró digamos que estaba en manuel
mccomb y el ministro de interior estaban
amenazados también de atentados posibles
es cierto yo me interrogó qué pasó hoy
día con sala más de slam que está en la
tribuna que está lanzando poco a poco
diatribas y mensajes un poco cómo va a
despertar no estoy especulando que tener
mucho cuidado tal vez con las palabras
que utilizan los medios nos tenemos que
hacer esa pregunta
hasta qué punto
transmisores como que lo que se dice los
elementos los informarse hasta qué punto
con qué imágenes
eusebio un gran debate incluso a nivel
mediático sí yo creo que
ha habido una como he dicho antes una
saturación mediática excesiva al inicio
de este juicio pero ya es casi
inevitable de la manera que financiaron
los medios yo creo que hay el elemento
de la victoria de los talibanes dentro
del contexto es importante también
porque en el fondo ha sido una derrota
no sólo de eeuu de óxido presidente verá
a estas personas otra vez en el poder
eso da alas al aunque haya diferencias
estratégicas
entre el estado islámico o al qaeda eta
y tal en el fondo es una victoria del
fundamentalismo islámico frente
occidente después de 20 años de guerra
de inversión
todo esto es evidente sin evitar le
queda alas a estas personas en todo el
mundo las envalentona para intentar
alguna acción y es un peligro es un
peligro ahora antes para ahora del
estado de alerta a propósito de los
servicios de inteligencia otra cuestión
que estos atentados pusieron sobre la
mesa fue la falta de coordinación sin
duda entre por ejemplo la policía
francesa y la policía belga alexandre
ágil se ha avanzado mucho durante este
lustro y estos seis años que han pasado
en este terreno de la información de
compartir la información entre los
servicios de inteligencia
si se han reforzado las herramientas
jurídicas sobre todo aunque permiten
y compartir información entre diferentes
diferentes estados claramente implicado
simplemente afectados por este fenómeno
y europa en su conjunto se ha reforzado
tanto a nivel estado como a nivel
europeo se han llevado a cabo medidas de
intensificación desde 2013 y esto es un
dato importante porque nos arroja un
dato optimista y al mismo tiempo creo
que tenemos que ser muy precavidos a la
hora de analizarlo se han desarticulado
más de 60 es más de 60 y
hay atentados sólo en francia y esto nos
arroja como digo un dato positivo porque
nos damos cuenta de que realmente están
funcionando las la cooperación con otros
con otros países de unión europea o las
propias medidas que francia está
aplicando estas medidas en la cárcel de
prevención de la radicalización y al
mismo tiempo nos recuerda que el peligro
es vigente pero el peligro continua y la
amenaza sigue estando allí
hablemos del contexto político porque
este macroproceso se va a celebrar
coincidiendo con la campaña electoral de
las presidenciales del año que viene que
impacto creen que va a tener o qué temas
derivados del macroproceso
van a establecerse sobre todo y ante
todo va a ser el tema de la seguridad la
seguridad interna la seguridad exterior
no hay que olvidar también que durante
el proceso cuando surgió la crisis
afganistán y la llegada los talibanes
con la llegada de refugiados también
afganos empezó a preguntarse la gente
qué iba a suceder hoy día que si era de
nuevos focos de radicalización o
islamismo yo creo que el tema hoy día va
a ser el tema ante toda la seguridad tal
vez hoy día las elecciones no la gente
está posicionando un poco
como las derechas y la izquierda y los
centros acá en este país van a empezar a
designar la agenda que nos va a atacar
digamos de alguna manera mediáticamente
en acierto y siguen pienso absolutamente
que hacer el tema la seguridad que va de
nuevo volverse en el tapete de la
información de como
y gritamos de nuevos atentados de como
los servicios de inteligencia fueron
fallidos en 1 minuto como de nuevo
reactiva lo que siguen decía que
efectivamente han habido cambios en la
legislación y las cooperaciones
internacionales también de qué manera
europa puede hacer frente a este nuevo
nuevo despertar o envalentonamiento como
decía anteriormente respecto al día
mismo pero es cierto que yo pienso que
políticamente ya lo vimos la semana
pasada lo vimos el proceso de afganistán
no estamos viendo días esta semana con
los atentados en con el proceso de los
atentados que los políticos ya empiezan
un poquito a lanzar pistas no la
seguridad la seguridad interna que pasa
a los servicios de investigación y sobre
todo un tema que es horrible decirlo la
inmigración de qué manera la inmigración
también va a estar en el centro de las
discusiones de cómo eliminación hay que
frenar la no frenar la bueno los temas
de que quieren tanto la derecha y la
extrema derecha cierto y en
instrumentalizar
efectivamente es cierto ciertos
elementos para poder
traer electores y hablar del miedo qué
mejor que darle miedo a la gente para
poder ganar cohesión la seguridad y
también el usuario nombraba antes ese
debate también del encaje de los
musulmanes en francia que también va a
impactar en supongo que tendría que ser
el debate fundamental porque es verdad
que es imprescindible la cooperación
internacional mejorar la labor de los
servicios de inteligencia pero en el
fondo de eso de poco va a servir si hay
una sociedad si hay un caldo de cultivo
para este radicalismo en este país se
está discutiendo en fase y avanzar al
parlamento una ley para intentar luchar
contra este radicalismo musulmán por un
nombre muy sintomático hablando de
separatismo en el pse para de que cree
quieren crear una sociedad aparte y ese
es un debate
muy importante
hace la amalgama y sólo musulmanes en el
mismo saco y que es una injusticia
absoluta porque no por días estúpidos
que hacen locuras en todos lados y que
aterrorizan a la gente una población que
vive en paz que bien tranquilidad en un
país eso lo que también es peligroso
durante las elecciones no estigmatizar
una población que ya basta estigmatizar
la para que vemos que por un lado la
crítica de siempre
encendida que sí que se hace esa
amalgama por el lado especialmente de la
extrema derecha pero también hay actores
sociales que enseguida tachan de
islamofobia cualquier intento de crítica
o de cualquier presentación de este
debate también el estado ha sido fallido
no solamente los servicios de
inteligencia sino que en que pase el
aceite en los suburbios franceses donde
los chicos no tienen otro remedio a
veces que ir y radicalizarse porque no
hay ninguna oportunidad de salir la
sanción social no existe en este país de
hace mucho tiempo y allí están los casos
de cultivo no hay que olvidar que todos
los que perpetraron los atentados en
francia son franceses les voy a
preguntar precisamente alessandra hill
por ello porque desde 2015 la
radicalización ha ido evolucionando a
nuevas formas y por nuevos canales
además alejandra lo ha comentado incluso
en este programa muchas veces de cómo
cambia incluso por redes sociales cómo
va evolucionando tecnológicamente cómo
son esos procesos de radicalización en
la actualidad en que han ido cambiando
desde 2015 ya desde la caída del estado
islámico alexandra el yihadismo global
creo si algo ha demostrado a lo largo de
las últimas décadas
por mi capacidad de mutación incluso
durante el cob y se han llevado a cabo
detenciones que han demostrado que pues
que dais se ha adaptado a esta amenaza y
ahora aprovechar un momento de
incertidumbre un momento de mayor
conexión a internet de soledad de miedo
a una pandemia
de aislamiento para para bono para
expandir para expandir está esta
ideología ha habido detenciones en
madrid por la detención en la que
después se demostró que estas proyectos
de radicalización se habían
intensificado durante la pandemia porque
porque era es sabe saber adaptarse
nombre eso es tan importante para la
prevención de la radicalización porque
es clave que este juicio ponga en el
foco en las víctimas de terrorismo son
ellas las que tienen que contar su
historia las que tienen que repararse y
son ellas las que tienen que ser las
protagonistas de este juicio no podemos
caer en
quitar esta mediatización extrema de
hacer de hacer de esto un poco pues un
un espectáculo que es lo que está
esperando por ejemplo el preso que al
que dieron la palabra es que el único
superviviente de los tratados de parís
de entre los terroristas que es alardes
landa podemos caer en ese
sensacionalismo porque le haríamos un
flaco favor a la democracia la
democracia necesita que las víctimas de
terrorismo sean la voz de la resiliencia
fíjense claro cuánta razón y qué
sensible es el tema no da el mismo
tiempo dar la voz a las víctimas y no
caer en un impacto mediático que ve a
las des la miel y al yihadismo es es
complicado el equilibrio y observen es
sensible todo si hay muchos factores yo
ahora pensaba también en los elementos
internacionales es decir hay un poco de
hipocresía cuando hablamos de la
radicalización aquí de los problemas en
los suburbios y las conexiones
internacionales y las influencias de
turquía de arabia saudí no enviando
imanes aquí radicales es un tema que es
muy difícil de abordar en este país
porque porque también francia vende
armas a arabia saudí tiene relaciones
con estos países
es decir que es muy complejo el universo
que se ha de estudiar en este problema
es muy complejo y hay contradicciones
también en la política de los gobiernos
una última frase de sujeto verbo y
predicado porque tenemos acabar de arma
razón sale tal vez del proceso del siglo
porque no solamente preso de veinte
acusados de la barra sino que todo un
sistema que es tentacular y que va a
abordar todos esos temas internacionales
locales de seguridad y sobre todo
societales pues muchísimas gracias
muy obediente muchísimas gracias para
darle a eusebio alexandra tendremos
nueve meses por delante para ver cómo
evoluciona este llamado juicio del siglo
aquí en francia ya todos ustedes les
esperamos la próxima semana quien en
primera plana muchas gracias
[Música]